Oh
the eyes the right 438 the nose to the
left 20
[Applause]
Beth there we have it so how is 20
against quite a few abstentions clearly
[Music]
colleagues we come now to the intended
business statement by the Lord President
of the Council and the leader of the
house mr. Jacob Riis more I think the
right honourable judgments pardon the
Honourable lady had signaled a desire if
the right honorable gentleman will
forgive me to raise a point of order
which he can do briefly budda orderly
several Roberts the old carry out
today's votes point of order has been
made by the leader in Westminster
applied come realists Abba Roberts but
what we're going to hear in a moment or
two is an announcement from the leader
of the House Jacob Riis MOG about how
they will wind up this Parliament the
business the the bills they've still got
to get through when they will be sent
back to their constituencies and no
longer become MPs and the campaign
proper will start so where the speaker
is going to reintroduce such as back
after making a ruling on the point of
order made by lists alvarado it's going
to reintroduce Jacob Riis more
determines what happens in these matters
subject to the overriding principle of
adherence to a clear rule the Honourable
lady ruling that from the speaker buff's
we are now in general election territory
all the debate all the discussion about
whether there would be one when it would
be it's all been sorted out in the
course of one single day and hours of
comments and MPs have voted
overwhelmingly and beasts of all parties
more or less have voted overwhelmingly
as you can see for yourself for a
general election to be held on the 12th
of December this year second week of
December